mille milliards d'euros ce serait le
coût annuel de la corruption au sein de
l'union européenne corruption présente
jusque dans les plus hautes sphères des
institutions européennes dans une
enquête de libération
on apprend que certains hauts
responsables de la cour des comptes
européenne abuse tous azimuts prime de
logement exorbitantes pour domicile
fictif notes de frais non contrôlés
absences injustifiées mission non
vérifié un comble pour un organe censé
surveiller le bon usage des deniers
publics européens 27 membres de la cce
sont obligés de vivre en permanence dans
le grand duché ou à la frontière
exactement comme les membres de la
commission doivent habiter à bruxelles
c'est là que doit se trouver le centre
de leurs intérêts familiaux ils
reçoivent pour ce faire une indemnité de
logement mensuelle de 15 % de leur
salaire 22000 430 euros 24000 pour le
président soit une prime comprise entre
3364 et 3600 euros à cela s'ajoute un
pécule de 40000 euros pour les frais de
déménagement et d'installation le
président justement c'est klaus meine
relève un ancien député européen
allemand proche de la cd ou d'anglais la
merkel un appartement figure à son nom
au luxembourg mais l'âme ne viendrait
sur place que pour les réunions où sa
présence est obligatoire soit un à deux
jours par mois environ la plupart du
temps il est résident ray en allemagne
dans la ville de düsseldorf depuis sa
prise de fonction à la tête de la cour
des comptes européenne
il aurait ainsi empoché plus de 325 1000
euros pour ces seuls frais de logement
325 1000 euros en guise d'appel aide
personnalisée au logement quelque sorte
tout ça pour ne pas habiter dans ledit
logement c'est loin d'être le seul un
tiers des membres de l'institution
n'habiteraient pas à luxembourg peut-on
donc logiquement parler de fraude pas
pour le principal intéressé
la plupart des allégations portées dans
l'article publié par libération sont
fausses les déclarations sont non
fondées et non véridiques comme
l'appartement mesure 160 m² j'en ai sous
louer une partie où et avec qui je vis
au luxe bourg relève de mes affaires
privées nous sommes en train de décider
s'il est judicieux de porter l affaire
en justice ou non klaus einer lang s'est
aussi dit prêt à fournir des documents à
deux membres de la commission de
contrôle budgétaire mais tenez vous bien
se refuse à soumettre la cour un audit
indépendant à raison invoquée par ce
contrôleur en chef ne souhaitant pas
être contrôlé cela donnerait une
mauvaise image de la cour des comptes
européenne et affecterait sa crédibilité
comme si cette cour n'était pas déjà
mise à mal par les révélations de
libération et le quotidien ne s'arrête
pas là conflits d'intérêts flagrants
pressions politiques appartement fictifs
dans un second volet il pointe du doigt
l'ensemble des institutions européennes
journal révèle un réseau de trafic
d'influencé dominé par le ppe le parti
populaire européen qui regroupe un
ensemble de partis de droite et
constituent la première force politique
de l'union européenne
depuis qu angela merkel a été élu à la
chancellerie en 2005 elle a placé ses
hommes à tous les niveaux de pouvoir
beaucoup d'allemands mais aussi des gens
de pays proches de l'allemagne
finlandais néerlandais flamand
autrichien et c'est ces gens
fonctionnent entre eux ils vivent dans
une bulle et la facilité des moyens qui
leur sont octroyés et de l'utilisation
de ces moyens leur fait perdre toute
éthique quant à l'utilisation de ce
pouvoir c'est cela que je démonte c'est
un état ppe qui verront l'union
européenne des révélations qui
pourraient poser quelques problèmes à
quelques semaines du début de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
emmanuel macron comptait sûrement sur
cette vitrine pour briller sur l'échelle
européenne à des fins électoralistes
puisque l'élection présidentielle
française a lieu en effet dans moins de
cinq mois une vitrine qui aujourd'hui en
dépit de la proximité de noël est loin
de briller de mille feux